hello and welcome back to yet another
video where we try not to only save your
time but also find some obscure shows
that might be worth your while the
island of giant insects follows a group
of students stranded on a seemingly
deserted island trying to survive
gigantic killer insects until rescue
comes with the context out of the way
let's begin the movie starts in an
airport we get introduced to the
characters by following the perspective
of a bee but the journey ends after it
pumps into the fist of a delinquent with
a messed up hairline after lights go off
for the bumblebee the camera cuts to
unconscious mutsumi on a beach she looks
around collects herself and then grabs
her bag and ventures inside the forest
where she finds the gym rat captain
ayumi the girls summarize the situation
that they're in and decide to look for
more people the silly hat girl
conveniently says that she has a pack of
[ __ ] banging on a vending machine
with sticks which the camera cuts to and
surprise surprise it's the [ __ ] up
hairline guy with friends trying to bust
open the machine which the well drawn
glasses hottie doesn't take nicely to
then the boys get approached by a smart
ass girl who advises them to drink water
or tea a sugary drinks dehydrate the
person even more to which the borderline
bald guy says are you worried you're
gonna get thirsty with me around [ __ ]
hashtag low blow my dude low blow after
such savagery a wild cougar enters the
scene she tries to convince the lackeys
to look for some food for her with the
reward being to enjoy a show of booba
but to my utter shock and disbelief they
pass on the offer as they suspect them
girls to be fake anyway i didn't expect
some random lackeys to have a little old
something called standards the group
pulls their phones out to find out but
sadly they're broken due to the crash so
the group decides to look for island
residents since they concluded the
island must be inhabited for it to have
a vending machine however before going
on their discovery adventures a girl
must pee and if you watched our previous
video about a group stranded on an
island with cannibal tribesmen you know
by now nothing good comes from peeing in
the woods a lesson the smart ass kids
soon learned when two huge butterflies
appeared from nowhere the cultured
butterflies used their tentacles to
check if the girls touchy is edible and
sadly due to youtube guidelines i can't
show you the whole sequence of what
happened so we'll skip to after when the
butterfly sucked the girl to death they
went to attack the rest of the group not
sakura is attacked in the most atrocious
cgi way the boys go to help the damsel
in distress but they get sucked to death
too reducing the number of characters so
we need to memorize their names anyway
moving on at the moment the stranded
girls enter the scene and the hat girl
starts laying some knowledge on us
explaining the type of these butterflies
flexing the amount of information she
has about all things bugs however the
tomboy isn't impressed as people are
dying right now the tomboy proceeds to
walk up and try stabbing the insects in
the back but the knife breaks doing
nothing or as the cutie pie puts it
then the ugly hat girl pulls a spray
bottle as well as a lighter and goes all
salem style on them burning one and then
sending the other one flying away now
down to four busty ladies one flat girl
and two virgins the group trade insults
as you do in a life or death situation
they stop when hearing what sounds like
a helicopter but it turns out to be
something more like a wasp that catches
my favorite character so far the glasses
beauty it stabs her in the back and
flies away mutsumi explains that it was
the kind of wasp that doesn't kill but
paralyzes its prey and they need to save
her before the wasp eggs hatches and the
baby wasps that will eat alive the host
but such a feat with the cowardly group
seems impossible as they refuse to go
however when the beta virgin notes his
phone still not working insect girl
remarks that chitose's phone is still
working and uses the gps not only can
she tell where they are but she can also
know the kind of bugs that live in this
hell hole greatly increasing their
chances of survival
while heading to the insect lactation
mutsumi with her very unfashionable hat
explains to the cowardly group how
they're more safe in the wasp nest
rather than the outside as this kind of
wasp rarely goes back to their nest and
then she proceeds to theorize how these
insects got so big in the first place
the group arrives to a house where the
wasps nest is they enter it and what
awaited them was a scene straight up
from a gory hentai the staff was hard to
see the maggots are feeding on people
that are being fed chemicals to feel
pleasure and no pain however when some
climb on the cougar the group starts
killing them consequently cutting the
stream of pleasure waking the people in
pain the group can't handle it so they
run back outside when they decide not to
go back in since the guy with dreads
took a working phone from a victim the
wasp comes back with a new prey mutsumi
orders the group to stand still so the
wasp doesn't notice them but when the
alpha virgin sees his friend as the prey
he acts up and follows the wasp inside
with a metal pole which isn't that
helpful as he was getting his ass kicked
mutsumi follows the guy and helps him by
spraying the wasp freeing him and
creating an opening for the baldi to
rescue his friend while mutsumi removes
an egg attached to chitose after finding
her she asks the big alpha for a hand to
pick up the sleeping busty but he
refuses spits and runs out like a little
b word sending me in a moment of blind
rage ruining my night but that isn't all
as a lack of loyalty didn't end there
when he managed to get out of the house
baldi tells the group to leave the gills
but thankfully captain ayumi had the
balls to go back in that wasp infested
house and save them
now outside the group checks on the
unconscious people mutsumi tells them
they need to get some sports drinks to
clear the venom the dread boy points at
a map of the island using it they go
their way to the next location while
marching the cougar questions insect
girl's knowledge as she assured them
that the nest would be empty to which
mutsumi responds no new bastards will
leave me alone to defend for myself i
used my monkey brain and called
reinforcement as in i sprayed the first
while split hair product and knowing
that wasps are attracted to the smell i
made sure others will come by covering
the house with some of it and when they
came they attacked the main wasp i mean
i might paraphrase there a little bit
something along those lines anyways
after showing she has the superior
intellect and clearly the higher moral
code she gets appointed as the new
leader of the group by the beta virgin
but the cougar still doesn't like it
tries to contest it however she gets
shut down after a giant tick appeared on
her lower back mutsumi hastily removes
it and looks for any scar since if the
tick penetrated the skin it can leave
some deadly diseases and the [ __ ]
doesn't end there as they soon find
they're in a hard tick nest mutsumi
picks up a rod and then orders the group
to curve their chest hide their hands
and walk slowly after that she throws
the rock and the ticks around it because
it was warmed up by their body heat and
thus they march slowly to safety as they
near the shore the group see a shadowy
figure that resembles their teacher as
she comes closer to light we see ticks
all over her face scarring the flat girl
the cougar tries to contain her but to
no success hence more ticks get
attracted to them back in the corner
mutsumi must take some difficult choices
which is hitting her already doomed
teacher to create a distraction as they
now run for safety while ticks fall from
the sky
now fellas we come to another sequence
of scenes that we can't show on youtube
so why not enjoy this cute cat video as
i tell you what happened essentially the
girls clean themselves at the beach some
yuri action occurs between captain ayumi
and not sakura and oh boy let me tell
you this pink hair girl she's a devious
one apparently she knew that the captain
of the softball club swings to the same
team so she uses that to seduce her in
the hopes that she'll become her
bodyguard while on the other end the
alpha virgin gets visited by the cougar
and seduces him away from his bros
losing not only his v card but also the
sight of his friend's unconscious body
that seems to have something moving in
it and with that being said i hope you
enjoyed the wholesome stuff the editor
chose the group make their way to an
abandoned building they split up and
look for some medicine and after finding
it they give mouth to mouth to the
unconscious fellows because at this
point why not make it the only way we
already strayed far from god meanwhile
the beta virgin is using the computer he
came across and then turns on the lights
as well as brings food to the group
later on the beater goes to stroll the
hallways and finds something so shocking
that the camera cuts to the alpha
friends who start moving but then we
hear the beater screams and bug sounds
which triggered the blondie making him
move as if he's possessed by a demon his
eyes do some cartoony [ __ ] and then goes
running away for this part now i'll be
taking over and explain myself as i've
watched plenty of national geographic to
know a parasite made this pretty boy act
like that the parasite that infected it
mainly infects insects to make them do
some suicidal behavior like strolling
the predator's nest to get eaten so the
parasite keeps on traveling and feeding
and multiplying see i told you i'm smart
but enough with this showing off back to
the movie yeah the alpha tries to save
his friend but he gets stopped by the
cougar in the last minute and they run
to the building trapping the rest of the
group outside on the claims of them
being infected the only people remaining
inside now are the alpha who's shown now
to be completely under the control of
the cougar and the sleeping busty who
wakes up and demands to see mutsumi but
as you guess the cougar doesn't take it
nicely and orders the alpha to defile
her when it looked inevitable we hear a
metallic bang and then the alpha went
face first to the ground with the cougar
following him the thing behind the bang
was none other than the beater who's
still alive earning the right to be
called by his name kai he saved chitose
and opened the doors for the rest of the
group after the girls finally get their
reunion the group goes to work they
cover the windows and come up with a
plan to raise the output of the lights
to attract the fly outside to its death
a cheesy soundtrack plays in the
background as mutsumi walks over so
slowly for what feels like a hundred
years i mean i swear to god that must
have been the longest tunnel to the
point that the sun's soon rising up by
the time she reached the end of it but
that doesn't detour her from going
through with her plan mutsumi goes
outside and starts preparing for the
quote unquote light of death after
finishing from the tower she made she
then hides behind a wall triggering a
loud siren disturbing the cgi nest and
me she runs around batting the fly to
the lighter when it gets there kay ups
the tower signal electrocuting the bug
the group then stand over the dead bug
chitto say hands mutsumi that ugly ugly
hat
my god i can't believe that it survived
in this movie this long moon to me then
cries for hurting them the poor insects
as if they weren't going for their heads
and soon after we see the cougar and the
baldy have woken up still tied up the
group finally decides to leave them
while they go to the next destination
under the leadership of chitosi ending
the movie on the most lame sentence
the last place we can find
that's exactly where we'll wait to be
rescued far away
where no one can bug us
if you made it to this point congrats
for having the attention span higher
than the average person nowadays i'd
like to thank you for being awesome and
sticking to this point so yeah thank you
very much if you've already liked and
subscribed know that we appreciate it
and we'll always try to entertain you
with that being said see you next time